okay it's time for this week's episode
of hatred mail quick reminder what is
hatred mail it's when a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of hate mail that I get quick
reminder it's like email for words from
your racist grandma on steroids Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom so I think that this hatred mail
is related to the news from last week
that the david pakman show youtube
channel reached 600,000 subscribers just
a fantastic milestone for us by the way
already at almost six hundred and ten
thousand subscribers just absolutely
amazing i think that that's what this
hatred mail is related to although I
can't understand exactly what point the
hey tree it's trying to make the fact
problem good point David does it get
lonely
does it get hard to pat yourself on the
back during the day and then stroking
your micropenis through the nights and
it's Pakman 600,000 subscribers right
like it's something pathetic
absolutely pathetic s-- are the numbers
on the David Pakman show YouTube channel
I don't know what the hell this person's
talking about but it does seem that they
were heavily triggered by the David
Pakman show reaching 600,000 subscribers
and since we can't really decipher what
it is that they are trying to say I will
just remind you that if you want to send
a middle finger salute to the hey tree
it's the best thing you can do is use
the coupon code hey tree at 40 when you
sign up on our website the coupon code
hey tree at 40 saves you 40% off of your
membership and it makes the hey tree its
cry because our support only grows every
time they write in so use that coupon
code hey tree at four th a t RI ot 4
zero it'll save you 40% off of any
membership whether it's the $6 a month
membership or the hundred and twenty
dollar a year membership or whichever
save 40% big win for everybody other
than the hatreds